die anspannung im gesicht
die waffe in der hand auf den straßen
londons steht sich myanmar zukunft
gegenüber junge soldaten auf der einen
seite junge demonstranten auf der
anderen kokorin ist einer von
hunderttausenden die sich auflehnen seit
dem putsch seit mehr als zwei wochen
weiter sich täglich in den protest wir
setzen auf friedlichen zivilen
ungehorsam
auch wenn die sicherheitskräfte gewalt
anwenden wir werden bei unserem
friedlichen protest bleiben und wir
geben nicht auf wir machen weiter bis
wir siegen
sie sind sich der gefahr bewusst
im angesicht des militärs dass aufstände
stets mit gewalt nieder prügelte
riskieren sie nichts weniger als ihr
leben
sie wissen was es für ihre zukunft
bedeutet wenn sie den kampf verlieren
das ist die entscheidende schlacht für
ihre freiheit sie haben erlebt wie die
generation ihrer eltern gelitten hat
nach dem putsch 1988 nach dem aufstand
wenn sie diesen kampf verlieren werden
sie ihr leben lang unter der knute der
militärs stehen
die bewegung ist jung ihr idol 75 jahre
alt sun tzu chi bis zum putsch im
zentrum der regierung verkörpert noch
immer alle hoffnung auf freiheit und
demokratie
sie steht wieder unter arrest doch ihre
aura lässt sich nicht wegsperren das
schicksal myanmar scheint einmal mehr
mit dem schicksal dieser frau verknüpft
robert cooper ist seit langem mit sushi
bekannt befreundet anfang der 70er jahre
lernten sie sich kennen
sie arbeitete für die uno in new york
sie war eine wunderschöne frau
sehen sie sich die bilder von damals an
auch heute ist sie ja noch immer sehr
attraktiv
sie war vergnüglich genoss das leben in
new york
aber schon damals sie war mitte 20 hatte
ich den eindruck dass sie immer vor
allem irland im kopf hat
ein freund hat mal zu ihrem verlobten
gesagt wenn du sie heirate schön aber
macht ihr nichts vor irland wird für sie
immer an erster stelle stehen
susis geschichte ist vom widerstand
geprägt sie kempf siege und niederlagen
ihre beliebtheit im volk machte sie
gefährlich die militärs stellten sie
unter hausarrest insgesamt 15 jahre
doch nichts konnte ihren mut brechen ein
seltenes interview ließ keine zweifel
ich habe mich immer frei gefühlt
meine werte meine prinzipien was für
mich zählt das konnten sie mir nicht
nehmen sie haben mich nie gebrochen ich
war immer frei sie ist die tochter eines
generals eines helden der sein land in
die unabhängigkeit führte der eiserne
wille vielleicht eher zu ziehen vom
vater
ich habe in meinem leben kaum jemanden
getroffen der starrsinniger ist ein c
ich hatte immer den ton angegeben durch
ihre familie ist sie so groß geworden
bist geboren um zu herrschen aber das
ist dabei wirklich wichtig der wald ist
für sie nie ein mittel
sie setzt auf überzeugung nicht auf
gewalt nicht auf befehl 2010 kommt sie
frei
das militär lockert seinen griff fall
myanmar internationale hilfe braucht
sushi wird zum aushängeschild sie öffnet
türen
seit 2016 kann sie als staatsrätin de
facto die regierung führen doch im
ausland kollabiert das ansehen der
friedensnobelpreisträgerin geradezu als
sie das brutale vorgehen der armee gegen
die roma-minderheit rechtfertigt sich
vehement gegen den vorwurf des
völkermords wert myanmar bleibt eine
demokratie von gnaden der generäle
bei den wahlen im vergangenen november
aber erreicht sie erneut eine
überragende mehrheit und mit ihr die
chance die fesseln der militärs
loszuwerden
sie drohte eine rote linie zu
überschreiten mit dem versuch die
verfassung zu ändern
die verfassung ist für das militär
heilig sie zementiert die macht des
militärs
aber sie will dieses land verändern sie
will demokratie nicht das was die
generelle darunter verstehen wenn die
von maßvoller demokratie sprechen heißt
dass das militär bestimmt und dieser
konflikt wird ausgetragen zwischen zwei
villen starken führern
das musste knallen general mit online
ist der große gegenspieler
offensichtlich mit persönlichen
ambitionen mit 65 jahren sollte seine
karriere als oberbefehlshaber im sommer
enden doch anstatt von der macht zu
lassen griff er nach ihren zwei mal hat
sich der general seither geäußert
versprach neue wahlen in einem jahr
dem sieger gehöre dann die macht ganz
demokratisch
doch alles was der general spricht
klingt auch wie eine drohung
die verfassung ist nach dem zentralen
grundsatz gebaut dass niemand über dem
gesetz steht
das ist die basis in jeder demokratie
so soll aus sanssouci vor gericht die
vorwürfe fadenscheinig verstoß gegen
import gesetze verstoß gegen korona
regeln als gs dem general nur darum die
konkurrenten aus dem spiel zu lassen
denn auf der straße bei den jungen
leuten sind die sympathien eindeutig
verteilt sotschi wird vergöttert mit
online verdammt der general hat nicht
mit dem widerstand der jungen leute
gerechnet als er die macht an sich riss
wie soll er jetzt frieden mit dieser
jungen generation schließen
sie werden nicht nachgeben und das
militär wird auch nicht nachgeben was
jetzt ist die große frage
und im moment hat darauf niemand die
antwort nur billig dienste herr finanzen
die anspannung auf den straßen maß
wächst und wächst
nerven behalten scheint jetzt das gebot
der stunde
es muss auf beiden seiten gelten nerven
behalten und friedlich bleiben
[Musik]